بالضبط
متوقع
إبحار
إنه ليس جزءًا من الشخصية التي اتصلت منها
طريق اخر
حسنا
حسنًا ، هناك مزيج من الأحاسيس
جانب
هناك بعض الحنين وهذا الحزن
ما الذي يمنحك الانفصال عنه
جيد للمجموعة خاصة للمجموعة
الإنسان الذي قصد الكثير في هذا
الوقت بالنسبة لنا ولكن أيضا
تأكد
الرضا عن كل ذلك
لقد قمنا بكل العمل وكل شيء
الحب وكل الطاقة التي لدينا
أودعت في تصوير بيت
دور وكذلك تريد أن ترى
قليلا ما تبقى و
أيضا للشروع في مغامرات جديدة
مشاريع جديدة
حسنًا ، أنا أيضًا لا أعرف هل هذا صحيح
مثيرة للغاية من الصعب
لتعريف ولكن
أنا حقا أريد أن أظهر هذا
الموسم أيضا لإنهاء
حرف من دنفر مما يجب تدريسه
التي صنعناها من كل هؤلاء
مخازن حتى يدعونا جميعًا
الفصول التي لن أستطيع دفنها
شخصية بالتأكيد ليست وأنا
في انتظار ما سيحدث متى
وصول بث الفصل الأخير
وافد جديد جيد
مع
محظوظ قبل كل شيء ولماذا بسبب
عندما أصل إلى المسلسل والمسلسل
كنت بالفعل من العالم وفجأة ذلك
شعرت بأنني محظوظ ومثل أ
هدية ولكن أيضًا
المسؤولية ومثل الدوار
هائلة لدخولها مثل المدرسة
جديد ليس مع شركاء كبار
مع الأشخاص الذين كانوا يعملون و
تفعل الشيء نفسه ثم دخلت جدا
خائفة من الحقيقة ولديها الكثير من الدوار
لكني استمتعت به حقًا
تعلمت الكثير و
أنا ممتن جدا لوجودي هنا
من الشعبية وأين يفعل
بخاخات القمع نعم أعتقد أنها فعلت ذلك
كان قليلاً على المستوى العام لم نفعل ذلك
علمنا
معلم قوي جدًا لشيء ما لدينا
صنع المنزل من يقول إنه يتعلق
الجميع لي لا يتركني
مفاجأة أفضل مفاجأة جدا
القوي هو أنه سيكون مفاجأة بعد يوم
اليوم لأنك اكتشفت فجأة أن هناك
بلد جديد ترى فيه
الشخص الذي تحصل منه على رسائل النادي
المشجعين
أعتقد أنه حتى لو كنا قد حلمنا
مع إسقاط المسلسل الذي سيكون لدينا
يمكن تخيل هذه الأبعاد
في العرض الافتتاحي
عالم
الإسبانية
dromader وهو يؤثر بالفعل على الحل
إنها ثروة كبيرة في النهاية
المثال الذي يدخل لاحقًا في التشكيل
جزء من المنزل الورقي بالفعل كممثلة
أنني كنت مثل شيء لديه الكثير
أهمية أن مسلسل منهم
لديها الكثير من الاعتراف الذي يساعد
من الان فصاعدا
أعتقد أنه عندما يكون الناس واحدًا
الإنتاج الإسباني هناك شيء ما
النافذة التي تفتح على البصر في اسبانيا
من الصعب صنع خيال عالي الجودة
من القادة قبله نعم أعتقد أنه يساعد
أن العالم فجأة معلق
من الإنتاجات الإسبانية الأخرى
ل
ال
البقية
إنه مكان ممتاز لأكسيل وصديقها
في الرومانية الجديدة أعتقد في الآخرين
أشياء أعتقد أنها في النهاية السلسلة
الكمال ترفيه ولكنه كذلك
سلسلة لمشاهدتها مع الفشار
لا نريد تحويله إلى
رمز الصرف
لكونك مجنون ما هو
يقول جايمي ربما ليس واحدًا
السؤال عن الخير والشر ولكن
بالضبط ما يمكن
جيد حسنًا ، فماذا يفعل لك في مكان ما
حان الوقت لتسأل نفسك أن الطيبين هم نفس الشيء
إنهم ليسوا جيدين والأشرار ليسوا كذلك
سيئ وجيد أن هذا صحيح
العصابة تقوم بسرقة جيدة
الآن والثاني ولكن جزء من الخطة
كما تتكون من عدم الممارسة
على الرغم من أنه من الواضح في النهاية
دعونا نرى بعضنا البعض قليلا مجبرين على ذلك
أدخل قليلاً في هذه اللعبة ولكن إذا كان
أعتقد أن الفكرة تجعلك تفكر
بطريقة ما لمن يريد الدخول
هناك
جيد ما هو جيد ما هو سيء
من هم الطيبون السيئون
حسنًا ، أعتقد أنها صغيرة
دعوة للتفكير في هذا بالطبع
نحن لا نمجد
التخريب أو السرقة أو العنف
أعتقد أن كلاهما عكس هذا
هو ما يمكن أن تضيع في الغرفة و
كل ما يستلزم الحكمة أن تقرأ من
من الأسرة التي تم إخطارها
آرثر جيد
بقدر ما يبدو أن النظرية
من الواضح أنه عدونا اللدود و
ثم شخصية مثل هذا لديك الكثير من المرح
تصوير جيد لدينا علاقة جيدة جدا
مع هنري و
إنريكي كممثل مضحك للغاية وهو كذلك
العديد من المشاهد المضحكة جدا
نشارك ثم الشخصية التي أنشأتها
التي لديها مهمة أساسية في هذا
السلسلة التي تمنحك القليل من
الكوميديا ​​تشاهد ظهور ارتورو وأنت بالفعل
من المضحك أنني لا أعاني في كثير من المناسبات
هذا صحيح ولكني أدرك أن كل واحد
بمجرد أن يكون لديك شيء غير طبيعي ، فأنت تعرف ذلك
شيء عظيم سيحدث
في
يعرض